ouvrir notre bibliothèque pour aller
rejoindre tiphaine failli faire pour la
sélection livre du jour pour nos enfants
nos enfants qui adorent qu'on leur
raconte comment c'était avant surtout
quand on était petit est ce que papa de
travailler bien l'école est ce que maman
était comme si à quoi joue et mamie
enfin bon on retombe en enfance et ont
rajeuni ce matin avec votre iphone
oui pascal vous le savez les souvenirs
de famille c'est un peu comme un grand
livre d'image
du coup deux auteurs ont décidé de
prendre leur parti et de raconter les
souvenirs de mémé dans cette série la
foi ou mémé de vincent cuvellier mari ou
piffaretti publié chez nathan alors
cette fois dans ce tome mai mais a
échappé aux guêpes
c'est elle qui raconte l'histoire
c'était un jeudi le jour où on ne va pas
à l'école et elle doit faire un truc
pour maman se rendre utile en gros alors
ce jour là elle part au village acheter
le journal de papa avec son copain et
1010 mimile vous le voyez on est à
l'époque c'est mémé qui vous racontent
vous voyez votre mémé vous raconter ça
et puis il tombe du coup sûr un nid
d'insectes et il se demande si c'est un
nid de guêpe ou d'abeille
au lieu de s'en éloigner évidemment
alors cette histoire est accessible à
partir de 3 ans et elle est très très
bien raconté on s'y croirait les dessins
sont très sympas et vraiment je vous le
conseille ça permettra aux très jeunes
enfants de discuter avec mes pour savoir
si c'était comme ça de ton temps moi
j'adore
pépé et mémé qui sont aussi avec moi
aime aussi vous avez un autre album de
fiction tout doux malheureusement tout
doux à nous proposer aussi de quoi
s'agit-il
eh bien ça s'appelle quand j'étais petit
de sarah o'leary et de julie mort stade
2 canadienne publiée à l'étagère du bas
parce qu'on n'a pas toujours été un
trépidant quand on était enfant parfois
il ya des timides des caractère doux et
jules demande à sa maman justement dû
raconter son enfance
alors elle est
10 et bien quand j'étais petit on
m'appelait plus car j'étais vraiment
minuscule et ma meilleure amie était une
coccinelle alors les dessins et bien de
julie mort stade vous plonge dans un
univers vous le voyez fantastique où
tout est à la taille et bien d'une
maison de poupée
on est entre alice au pays des
merveilles et tom pouce vous le voyez
c'est très très joli c'est très doux
comme univers parce qu'on n'a pas dit
qu'il fallait que tous les souvenirs
soient réalistes un évidement mais quand
on est si petit bien ça donne envie de
grandir pascal
enfin bon pas question pour autant
d'oublier l'enfant qu'on est n'est ce
pas tiphaine et oui et c'est le parti
pris d'henri blackshaw 1 dans ce livre
publié par cette jeunesse qui s'appelle
et bien vous le voyez un livre pour
savoir à quoi ça ressemble d'être un
adulte et dans ce livre est bien très
clairement les adultes sont représentés
avec leur enfant intérieur alors vous
voyez ça peut être un enfant sportif
boudeur ou colériques et ça permettra
aux enfants d'être moins étonnés et bien
quand ils nous verront faire une petite
danse de la victoire ou ou bien triché
honteusement et je ne pense à personne
du coup j'ai vu comme ça il se livre à
lire en famille à partir de 10 ans 5 ans
et puis je pense que les enfants
s'amuseront à à percer à jour votre
enfant intérieur shooteur moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé un tout dernier livre en
quelques secondes s'il vous plaît
tiphaine parce que oui parce qu'on en
rit et on parle des livres pour les tout
petits mais c'est un sujet très sérieux
vous savez cette histoire d'enfant
l'intérieur et de ce qui forge notre
personnalité donc pour les adultes j'ai
ce livre de vincent de gaulejac qui
s'appelle dénouer les noeuds sociaux
psychique quand le passé agit en août
publiée par odile jacob
et ça vous montrera et bien que les
souvenirs d'enfance doivent être
partagés ainsi que le contexte social le
contexte historique dans lequel on
brandit vos parents et vos grands
parents
ça permet de comprendre comment se forge
la personnalité je le conseille aux
adultes
et puis évidemment pas partager mon
histoire de famille
i en inventant un peu peut-être est de
bon ton de m il était une fois avant une
belle histoire en tout cas merci
typhaine une belle sélection livre à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux ayant
appelé évidemment sur france 3 point fr
dit